So today's topic, Dave, Chappelle's new comedy special. Now,
if you haven't heard,
Dave Chappelle has come out with a new comedy special that came out on Netflix
and it's been, uh, pretty much drawing a lot of criticism,
as well as a lot of positive reviews.
Obviously with the last couple specials that Dave released,
he got a lot of flack from the LGBTQ community,
as well as other liberal medias who said, Hey Dave,
you're in a little right wing. We feel your views are a little extremists.
We don't like it. But now coming into this one, everyone was curious,
what direction was he was gonna go? And you could tell that for Dave,
he wanted to make it clear that he wasn't going to back down just because
criticism was coming his way. And what made that clear for me?
Wasn't just the content. But also if you look at the intro,
it starts off with a couple of Ken mark cooks.
Yes. And then if you listen, he uses a print song 1999. Yeah.
And if you listen to the lyrics,
I'm gonna just read off the lyrics for you guys.
The sky was all purple that where people were running everywhere,
trying to run from destruction, you know, I didn't even care. Say, say 2000,
zero, zero party over oops. Out of time.
So tonight I'm gonna party like it's 1999,
because if you remember 2000 was supposed to be the end of the world. Yeah.
The bug, the big bug and everything, right.
That was when prince wrote this in 1985,
that song and 1990 was supposed to be the last year that we were gonna be able
to be alive. Cuz the year 2000 was gonna be the one.
And so when Davis setting this up with the whole six in, in stones thing,
basically what he's saying is that he recognizes that his words and what he's
gonna say and might mean the end of what he's doing.
Yeah. Right.
But he's gonna go in and he's gonna party like it's 1999 cuz he doesn't give a.
He's gonna stand by his guns.
And even calling it sticks in stones is really just a jab at saying, Hey man,
you guys are, come from me, come me. But recognize these are just warts.
They can't actually harm you. So that was kind of the setup to let you know,
okay, this about to go in, get ready for it.
We're gonna read through some of the criticism,
the first one being from Buzzfeed news. Oh right there.
What's the most embarrassing public statement you've ever made that you've had
to walk back as a Sagitarius and a former conservative and
evangelical Christian, a quiet <laugh>
you good? I'm good. All right. So as a Saari you know,
<laugh> it's crystal clear bandwagon. That's only, uh,
being brought up because while he isn't supporting Trump outright,
although when discussing what he do of Trump won again, Dave Chappelle said,
I'll get a big tax break. That's obviously a joke. Yes. That's a joke.
That's that's you will get a tax break, man. Those people do not get irony.
If you don't like that don't wash that. That's one of the first thing he said,
you pressed on his face.
You knew what the hell you was getting into you press on his face.
Then you get offended.
It's like me putting my ahead and fired and get off at the lighter because I got
burnt. That makes no sense. Now you're just gonna be like this.
I wonder how God it. lighter.
See how dumb you look.
He effectively becomes an example of someone who doesn't give a about any issue
to do anything but speak his mind. I mean, listen, uh, that's not true.
He endorsed, uh, democratic candidate, Ben jealous. Why are.
You, uh, endorsing him when you don't usually get involved in endorsing.
Candidates? Uh,
the idea that Dave Chappelle has new ever wanted to be involved beyond his
words. It is not true. It's not because you don't see it,
that it's not happening.
Dave is very involved in town halls in this small town of Ohio.
So I am trying to be bound and fair.
But what I did wanna know is what is this pool of law enforcement that you
can pull the chief out of that is special enough to police this town,
which is wildly weak. So I would,
I would be the council to look deeply and to look hard
because I mean, we got, I mean, this is a golden opportunity.
Literally could kill the game. And this Trump era,
there's an opportunity to show everybody that local politics, reign Supreme,
we can make our one of the world outstanding.
So I'm just begging you to find a candidate that matches the culture of this
town, which is, which is incredibly unique,
which is renowned for being incredibly unique. That's all I want to say.
Thank you, David.
Dave is a very involved person. He's just not all up in social media.
So he may not be the Kaepernick of the social movement. He may not be, you know,
oh, Jay-Z, I'm working with the NFL type of partnership,
but he's doing a lot of stuff that you don't know because you haven't done your
research.
A lot of people have these platforms doesn't mean that you should be doing the
writing. Mm. All the worst white people love Dave Chappelle sticks and stones.
The worst people liking something, doesn't make that thing necessarily bad.
Right? Some of the worst white people as you put it like white,
does that make that is delicious.
So that's not even a <laugh> that's not a case.
Some people are getting mad because a lot of far, right,
right wing people are loving this special. You know,
the reason why they're loving this special is because the left has engaged in
these boycots in this banning of speech for so long that when they see an artist
actually mocking and skillfully making fun of those communities,
what they see as justice.
Because for so long people haven't been allowed to make these jokes.
Now they're like, oh yo, here's an artist. Who's making fun of everybody.
And so of course these right wing fingers are gonna prop him up because you guys
have engaged in silencing so many voices for so long that now when someone
doesn't listen to you, the right's gonna be like. Yeah. And,
and here's the other thing, right? Somebody said,
why are you punching down against trans people? Okay, listen, I, I need,
I need this to stop this trope that the alphabet people are somehow this weak,
uh, community of people who have no influence.
They're not you the way that they got Kevin Hart removed from the academy
awards. You see the way that they can, you got canceled. I got canceled. Well,
that's a different story for a different day. Right? Okay.
They get a lot of people canceled from a lot of different events.
People's careers are ruined just because the levy court against them.
And so this idea of the alphabet people are somehow these weak people who have
no political power and no clout is wrong. And so if eyes,
a black person can take jokes about black people,
then you as a trans person should also be able to accept jokes about you.
You say it denies your humanity. It's not denying your humanity.
It's just realities of your existence that are funny. And you know,
whenever we have disabled people at shows, right?
One thing they always ask us is like, yo,
don't treat me differently than the others. If you're gonna make a joke,
make a joke, don't make me feel excluded. Or I'm some kind of protected class.
I don't know when it comes to trans people,
why they feel like any joke against them is absolutely unacceptable.
That means to me that you guys don't actually wanna be treated equally.
What you guys want is preferential treatment.
What you guys want is power and control.
You want to be able to control other people's speech through boycot shame.
And you want to make sure that they talk the way that you want.
It's interesting because oftentimes the most controversial of topics,
because there's tension around them, right? Because there's so much, uh,
I can't talk about it when to is able to cut through that and actually discuss
the topic at hand. You know, when the punchline is delivered, the,
the laughs are even louder. Their reaction is even bigger.
The appreciation for the comedian is even larger. Why?
Because all that tension that build up from this taboo subject is now being
released through the punchline.
And that's the benefit of being able to tackle these topics.
If you always go for what's safe and what's easy,
people are not gonna find that. Interesting.
We don't go to skate parks to watch Tony Hawk skate back and forth.
We watch him because we wanna see him do a cool move.
Majority of us watch sports to watch people do the most extremist stuff.
So it would make sense that when I watch a comedian and deliver a joke,
I want him to talk about the most extreme of topics in the most extreme,
skillful ways. It's a good, special to me, uh,
that I laugh. Fortunately, I don't laugh at comedy anymore. I'm dead inside.
The reason why the reason being is I don't,
I don't laugh as often as I was laughing when I first started to do comedy,
because now I always, I, when I listen to comedy, I I'm working.
I'm working, I'm learning, I'm in school when I listen to comedy.
So if you guys aren't aware of both me and preachers stayed up comics to do this
full time. Yes. So since I started doing this full time,
and since I started doing this comedy thing, I don't laugh as, see,
there's a difference between me when I was laughing before at comedy. <laugh>
wow. That's funny. And now was a comic. That's funny.
And it's just like a chef. When a chef tasted on the chef's food, it's,
it's analyzing all the, and all the ingredients put in. Yeah.
We understand the importance of cadence time and storytelling, inflection,
everything. So we're analyzing,
so me laughing at something is not a good indicator of whether I like something
or not. Cause I'm always trying to find the thing, you know what I mean?
I'm trying to find all the spices and everything and stuff and the SIAG already,
or how he did that. I'm trying to predict the next punch.
And if I predict the next punch, I'm disappointed. Ooh, spicy.
I was not expecting that good job. You know what I mean? Like, but yeah,
I would give it like a, a solid eight point 75. So,
uh, I'm a pretty tough critic when it comes to, uh, uh, comedy specials. Um,
I've very familiar with Dave Chappelle's works.
I've watched quite a lot of his specials. Pretty much all of them. Yeah. Uh,
and um, I would probably say, uh, I I'm gonna give this special a 10.
It was the first special that I saw in a long time. That felt special. Yes.
That, that was my entire point. You know what I mean? When we say people say,
I'm gonna put on a one man show one hour long show, no,
you got a bunch of 50 minute shows that you put together,
but it's not a real one hour show, not special.
You got four minute 50, 4,
50 minute episodes and you put it together to a movie,
but it doesn't mean it was an actual,
and that's why this one's very memorable for me because I'm going to remember a
lot of the bits that came out of this one. And at the end of the day,
even if I didn't laugh throughout the whole thing,
what really matters with any piece of work of art is the impact it had on you as
a fewer cause I've been to comedy shows, but I've laughed throughout.
But I don't remember a single punchline that that person did. Nope. Right,
right.
Because sometimes laughs are there and you can see where the funny is what it
doesn't mean. It really hit home. Well, Dave,
not only did they get a couple laughs, but I really got a lot, couple like, Ooh.
And guess what the S are just as good as high. Yes, yes, yes.
That's a good point. Yes though. S because good as the high,
because you don't just go to comedy shows to laugh.
You go to comedy shows to feel,
you go to comedy shows to witness absurdity. And honestly,
if it can make you react,
that means that that artist has said words that hits you right in your gut,
that hits you somewhere where it matters and that it reminds you that yo I'm
alive right now. And that's what we go to comedy for.
I think he's the greatest storyteller standup has ever seen when I watch his
specials. Don't always get that sensation. But with this one,
especially I felt like there was a reward for watching it in its entirety.
In one city. I felt like because I did, I got a payoff at the end.
And I felt like what he started with was gonna matter with what ended that every
theme he aborted that, that,
that every theme that he touched was relevant to the entirety of,
of the special itself. And that's what made this special. So great.
I've seen D Chappel deliver better jokes.
I've seen him deliver far more punchlines. Some of it was a little predictable,
but I honestly also think that the reason why it wasn't so punch liney,
uh, with some of his, uh,
jokes was purposeful because sometimes when you are trying to make point
and have a funny point at the end,
sometimes you go overboard with the punchlines just to really drive home the
last with the audience and really drive home the reaction.
I think with this one,
when he would say something that he knew was gonna hit home for the audience,
he wanted it to sit there. Yeah. And don't forget,
ladies and gentlemen sticks and stones may break your bones,
but words will never hurt you.
That was the whole point of day Chappelle's thing.
We hope that our speech didn't bother you too much. We hope that it did.
Maybe for some people, you know,
look at you with the lube and look at you with the lube. I mean, I, I want,
I want, I wanna, I wanna make impactful episodes. You know what I'm saying?
Look at you with a special, you know what I'm saying? The YouTube special. Yeah.
Look at you. Yeah. With that demonetize money. <laugh>
I got some demonetized money here, so that's it for today's episode.
Leave your comments below. Tell us what you thought about the special,
some of the actions to it. Uh,
we want to hear what your favorite bits were in the comments below and, uh,
yeah, please.